So I think the most important thing you
can do in the early days trying to get
people to come work for
you is beg really well.
And there's some truth to that, really.
But the thing you can offer people
at that stage of a company is
impact and vision and passion and
that they can't get anywhere else.
I mean sure, you need to set up
the incentives and compensation so
that it makes sense.
They're going to make a sacrifice
joining you early in this journey,
almost certainly, right?
There's some opportunity cost for you.
There's some opportunity cost for
your early employees.
And that could last years.
So you want to set up incentives
in such a way and compensation and
such such a way that it's fair and
equitable, equity.
But the thing that you really offer
them, I mean everybody offers equity.
And it's worth the paper
it's printed on, literally.
What you can really sell people on and
really get people excited about is
the impact they'll have and the vision
that you have and the product itself and
the changes that you can make.
Even if it's just, it doesn't have
to be a world changing product.
But the ability,
people want to have an impact.
The kind of people you want to hire
desperately want to have an impact.
And that's what you can give them that
they can't, they go to a larger company,
that impact is necessarily diminished.
And so I always talk more about
the impact and the learning and
the roles and
the fact that they will be making more
decisions then they'll probably make
it any other time in their life.
And the right people for those early
hires will just gravitate towards that.
And the sort of compensation in dealing
with the sort of sacrifice that they're
making, the opportunity cost of
their incurring, is just details.
You just get them excited about
the impact that they can have.